big changes are coming to my channel so
i'm really excited guys to announce a
few big changes that are coming to my
channel but first wanted to say thank
you for watching and subscribing and
commenting and liking the videos i
really started this channel selfishly as
a way for me to stay motivated as an
entrepreneur and also try to give back
and it's hard to explain the feeling you
get when you know that people are loving
the stuff that you're doing and they're
feeling impacted so you guys give me
huge joy every day it means so much to
me and i'm going to announce three big
change to the channel that hopefully
will add more value to you ongoing the
first change isn't going to have daily
top 10 videos so the top 10 videos i
started as once a week and then i
expanded to twice a week and my goal was
always to have it as a daily thing
during the week to give ideas and keep
people inspiring and motivated but i
always felt like there wasn't enough
people to profile could we do 200 plus
people a year it felt like it was too
big a number but you guys have left so
many requests for people that you want
to see that we're far over and above the
200 names already and so it's time to
move to that format that I always wanted
to do the challenge is it's a lot of
work to make one top 10 video takes so
much research time as well as editing if
we look at that 50 cent video that came
out recently that took over 10 hours of
research just researching video clips
and putting them together that's not
including the editing time to put it on
and so I'm hiring somebody to help me do
that and their full-time role is going
to be researching video clips to help me
make these top 10 series it's worth it
because it really adds value and
increases the production quality of the
videos and hopefully has a big impact on
you guys 50 cent saw that video he
called it good and he posted it on his
facebook page and his Twitter channel
and on his blog and so that's my goals
to continue to produce
amazing quality were that if that
entrepreneurs sees the video they're
going to be proud of it and want to
share it and hopefully for you guys
watching you get inspired and motivated
by it as well so what this means is now
there's going to be three videos a day
on the channel during the weekdays and
some people are written in to say to
video today is too much heaven why don't
you do three times a week but why don't
you pare back a little bit and I've
always seen my channel not as a show but
as a channel I've always seen it as
something way bigger than just one show
that you tune into and I see the ents
presso as a show I see the top 10 as a
show I see the ass Kevin as a show and I
don't expect everybody to watch every
single video what I'm hoping is that you
take what works for you the parts that
you love the most and you can directly
apply to your life in your business and
just consume those just like you don't
sit there and watch you know every show
on NBC or HBO when you turn it on you
pick and choose and so I've never had
that limiting belief that I'm only
producing one show and I can only
produce you know three shows a week I
see myself as a channel and ideally
would like to create more content than
three videos a day but that's where I'm
going to start with now as soon as I
decided to move to those three videos a
day my next thought was christina is
going to kill me because she does all my
video editing does a fantastic job and I
didn't know if she could keep up because
she's already pretty much at capacity
and so I'm hiring not just a researcher
but also hiring another video editor to
help me manage the capacity and it's
actually going to be Christina's husband
so he's also video editor and he's going
to be out in his flavor to help me make
the videos even better hopefully
Christina her husband work well together
in life as I do in business and we
create amazing videos for you guys to
watch number two is I'm going to be
creating a new series called believe
life and this is something I want to
launch on the weekends and this is
another selfish project for me so when I
started the ants press 0 in the top 10
it was selfish for me because I wanted
to start my morning with something
and exciting motivating something that
make me think bigger one thing that I
feel is missing in my life is a little
more diversity beyond just
entrepreneurship and how I can live a
better life and so the idea with the
belief life series is to show clips and
inspiring footage to make you think how
you can approve other areas of your life
so for example I might be related to
your family might be related to showing
gratitude it might be something about
meditation or something about working
out I don't know I'm an open book right
now and I might check curious to know
what you guys think about it what area
of your life you want to improve beyond
business leave that in the comments
below and just like we base the top 10
series and in special series based off
of your feedback I love to create the
belief life series around your feedback
too so if there's something that you
really want to get better at outside of
business leave it down below and and
we'll see what you knew that might be
the first belief life video number 3
Nina's gonna be helping me out with the
comments this was a really tough
decision for me because i love the
comments i love you guys it's one of the
best parts of my day is answering your
comments and seeing your feedback and
your suggestions and your ideas and i am
already at a breaking point there are
some days where I'm up two three four or
five in the morning just respond in the
comments because I want everybody who
leaves a comment to get at least an
acknowledgement I don't know is it
something that feels like if you took
time can we become
I want to try to reply to it but it's
getting to the point where it's just
insane and Christina who's five or six
hours ahead of me in terms of the time
zone will often wake up and say you're
still up is it are you still up later is
it an early morning for you or like no
it's it's five in the morning i'm still
working away and and so that's not
sustainable and so Nina's going to be
coming and helping out on the comments
and unfortunately youtube doesn't have a
great way to show all the comments so
she's going to be replying to my account
which is the only way to see it the
difference is you're going to see a
cheers Nina at the end of all of Nina's
comments she's already started doing
that you guys are burning interacted
there if you want to hit me with a
message directly just tag me and that
gets sent to my email and i'll reply
i'll still be there in the comments to
responding joking having fun with you
but Nina's coming on board to help me
with the comments as a whole so those
are the three big changes that I'm
making it on the channel probably going
to make some mistakes along the way work
out some bumps and bruises I appreciate
your support your ideas your feedback
your thoughts your comments as we kind
of grow through this transition phase my
my goal at the end is I hope that we're
producing more quality content to help
you be inspired to grow a successful
business and have a huge impact on the
world so thank you guys for your support
and really appreciate it continue to
believe and I'll see you soon